effectivement dans quelques semaines les
élections européennes son caddie donne
la parole aux martiniquais susceptibles
de figurer sur une liste aux
martiniquais aussi bonjour béatrice
venez donc de joindre aux éditeurs
première secrétaire de la fédération
socialiste de martinique et candidate
aux européennes
du 26 mai sur la liste ps place publique
avec raphaël glucksmann en quelle
position c'est déjà déterminé ça pour
l'instant oui en 14e position
c'est européenne représente une
difficulté pour les socialistes ps qui
est bien triste mais les deux parties ne
se porte pas très bien olivier faur son
patron n'a pas encore trouvé la recette
pour rassembler fédérer et dynamiser et
pourtant il faut y aller à cette
bataille
je pense que vous êtes mal au fait de
l'actualité puisque en l'occurrence il
s'agit d'une liste de rassemblement
place publique iiec nouvelles donnes iec
lui des hyènes donc c'est pas mal parti
socialiste principalement du parti
socialiste parce que le parti socialiste
reste un parti qui a 100 ans et qui a
encore une certaine force même s'il est
affaibli
donc oui le parti socialiste est
probablement le plus important en terme
de
on va dire pas de poids parce que
finalement nous avons également décidé
de partager cette liste à 50 50 avec 50
socialiste et 50 personnes de
rassemblement et d'autres partis donc
vous avez vous réfugiez d'ailleurs une
union pour dix ans nous réfugiant
derrière rien du tout monsieur revel
temps nous faisons le rassemblement
parce que nous avons constaté qu'il y
avait
nécessité à gauche de pouvoir avancer
ensemble
je crois que la réalité en tout cas
aujourd'hui des sondages montrent qu'on
a un émiettement de des intentions de
vote
donc il fallait prendre une décision une
décision qui peut paraître douloureuse
pour certains mais qui sera probablement
salutaire à l'avenir il y à 2 0 pour
cette union
la contestation sociale l'action du
gouvernement même s'il s'agit d'une
élection européenne non justement ce
important et c'est pas même s'il s'agit
d'une élection européenne aujourd'hui je
crois qu'on a un défaut c'est qu'on
connaît mal l'union européenne l'union
européenne c'est près de 700 12 15
alors ça va peut être évoluer encore
d'ailleurs l'expression de l'autre la
question du break site et plus de 28
pays
la l'union européenne c'est aucun groupe
majoritaire d'accord donc ce qui veut
dire que il y a six groupes
parlementaires il faut à chaque fois à
l'union européenne
savoir faire des compromis avec les gros
parce que vous vous parlez avec des pays
qui n'ont pas obligatoirement la même
structure que vous qui n'ont pas choisi
le même type de développement économique
et donc vous fait alliance avec des
personnes de pays différents et en
l'occurrence le parti socialiste a eu
pour habitude de siéger avec les
socialistes et démocrates
mais au dessus de ce groupe des
socialistes et démocrates il est un
parti de droite
l'union européenne et depuis 30 ans à
droite donc là là ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que delà des directions des dpi
des pays membres il y a une majorité à
droite est temps que les gens à l'europe
continueront à voter à droite ils auront
des politiques de droite donc des
politiques libérales et puisque vous
parlez du parti de monsieur macron
monsieur macron et son parti ont décidé
d'aller siéger chez les libéraux les
démocrates libéraux mais chez les
libéraux et ces mêmes libéraux se sont
eux qui se font en l'occurrence c'est
pas béatrice mêlée qu'il dit c'est
prouver parce que c'est obligatoire et
ses publics
c'est ce groupe qui s'appelle la lbe
et par ailleurs financé par des grands
groupes et par ailleurs celui qui reçoit
le plus de lobby
alors moi je dis simplement martiniquais
aujourd'hui qui se pose la question de
ses de ces européennes qui se posent la
question du développement de notre
territoire fait les bons choix
si vous continuez aujourd'hui ce qui
n'est pas obligatoirement je termine
monsieur viol temps je vais vous décider
non mais je termine lorsque c'est
important lâcher un message aux
martiniquais
donc je dis aux martiniquais qui est
important qu'ils aillent voter parce que
ça détermine notre capacité de
développement et le co financement de
nos projets et plus singulièrement c'est
important parce que nous avons un
programme spécifique des routes qui
s'appelle le posei et qui est important
dans le développement de l'agriculture
et la transition écologique de notre
agriculture comment faire comprendre aux
martiniquais qui traditionnellement eux
s'abstiennent beaucoup pour les
élections européennes
comment faire comprendre aux
martiniquais tous ses rouages de l'union
européenne allant qui sont qui sont
frappés par une crise sociale une crise
sociétale une crise économique comment
leur faire comprendre que l'europe
pourrait être une réponse à leurs
besoins leur demandent à leurs attentes
à leurs préoccupations
mais je pense que vous vous poser la
bonne question parce que nous sommes au
bon endroit
je pense qu'il faut aussi des médias qui
soit capable in singulièrement le média
public de de consacrer du temps
également à l'explication sur ou en tout
cas à la définition des institutions je
crois que ça manque un peu et que ça
pourrait être en effet des sons de taux
intéressant à vivre mais non c'est non
mais ça arrive on en attend les enjeux à
venir la liste de diffusion de nos
modules sur l'union très bien très bien
non mais c'est de façon plus régulière
pas juste la veille des élections c'est
ce que je vous demande pas la veille des
élections
la visite aux martiniquais en quoi
l'europe pourrait être la réponse à
leurs solutions à leurs problèmes paris
ou bruxelles
ou les deux non tout tout tout il faut
faire feu de tout bois
en martinique on votre votre collègue
vient de faire un éditorial qui est
significatif
il faut faire feu de tout bois il faut
faire feu de tout bois localement parce
que il faut une politique
martin 15 économique de développement de
cohésion sociale qui soit en phase avec
notre besoin il faut aussi une politique
éducative sportive et culturelle qui
fait soit en phase avec notre
gouvernement qui évoque sur ma faim ils
sont assez bons à nos frais ils font
campagne justement pour les européennes
gilles catoire de madame germain n'a
rien à proposer d'ailleurs elle est
venue nous parler de de sport santé nous
on lui demande simplement de venir nous
parler de santé de venir nous parler de
nos hôpitaux de venir nous parler de des
politiques publiques et l'aurait incité
à mettre en place sur le traitement des
malades
suite à l'un géré l'ingestion de
pesticides tels que le chlordécone tels
que le glyphosate telles que l'asie
locks pour lesquelles ce même
gouvernement produit encore et encore
des arrêtés de dérogation spécifiquement
pour les territoires d'outre-mer
alors que madame gérardin ne vienne pas
nous tuer d'un côté en ne faisant pas ce
qu'il faut pour la santé des maisons de
quatre journées revendiquer non et
revendiquer c'est à dire que le il faut
que les masques tombent pouvait pas
parler de sport et santé
et puis permettent de l'autre côté que
les martiniquais sont empoisonnés tous
les jours dire aux martiniquais
alors que nous sommes sereins linke ne
pouvons pas nous échapper quand ils
peuvent continuer à ingérer comme ça des
pesticides et avoir leurs terres
polluées toujours et on sent remonté
contre le ministère je n'ai rien à dire
à monsieur le ministre de la culture
puisqu'il n'a pas été capable de
défendre notre chaîne ultra marines
france ô et que c'est toujours les mêmes
qui devront aller se battre et je trouve
que des attaques d'ailleurs à l'endroit
des outre-mer et de ce gouvernement sont
infâmes et sont nombreuses mais je vous
parle pas des congés bonifiés tout ça on
en parlera on en parlera dans quelques
années lorsqu'il s'agira de faire le
bilan justement de cette période où les
martiniquais est originaire et les
ultramarins en général venait se
ressourcer et venait aussi consommé sur
notre territoire mais en revient aux
européennes
béatrice est belle et justement pour
parler de nos pays de ces régions dites
ultrapériphériques
il faut des martiniquais d'eros 36 ans
de nos pays en bonne place aux bonnes
positions en tout cas en situation
d'éligibilité
pour pouvoir porter notre parole que
pensez vous de cette situation a priori
beaucoup
non mais encore une fois on voit s'il
attaque de ce gouvernement il n'y en
aura pas beaucoup pourquoi parce qu'en
février 2018
monsieur macron voyant qu'il n'avait pas
d'implantation territoriales a décidé de
remettre en place ce qu'on appelle la
liste nationale ce qui veut dire
qu'avant nous avions des listes
régionales donc les ultra marins avaient
la certitude de siéger la certitude de
siéger au parlement européen
sachant que nous avons un statut
particulier certains un député européen
nationale en tout cas qui vient de
l'hexagone continental enfin du
continent ne va pas aller siéger sur les
commissions qui concerne les régions
ultrapériphériques les régions
ultrapériphériques c'est le traité de
lisbonne c'est un statut particulier
donc nous nous revenons nous nous
relevons d'un statut particulier si les
ultramarins ne siège pas
les autres nient siègeront pas si les
ultra marins français ne siège pas les
autres ne vont pas aller siéger dans les
réseaux ultra périphériques n'ont rien à
y faire
alors pourquoi le parti socialiste place
publique ne vous propose je suis en 14
ans je suis en 14e position monsieur
vialleton je vous assure que je me dit
pour encore évoluer sur cette liste et
pour faire entendre également dans mon
parti mais la réalité c'est que avant de
faire entendre à mon parti faut que je
fasse à entendre à mes compatriotes
qu'il est important qu'ils aillent voter
qu'il est important qu'ils aillent
dépose d'un bulletin et qu'il est
important qu'ils manifestent leur
intérêt pour la présence aussi des
ultramarins sur sûr dans ce parlement
mais la réalité donc je vous disais
c'est que monsieur macron a décidé de
supprimer les listes régionales et pire
devant un amendement sollicitant un
amendement socialiste se dit citant le
maintien de la circonscription
d'outre-mer
il a préféré dire non ils se sont
opposés à ce que les ultras hommes les
outre-mer est le maintien d'une
circonscription
voilà la réalité et monsieur maman mais
monsieur macron vous avez vu ce qu'il a
fait je vous raconte pas l'histoire ce
qu'en l'occurrence à concerne quelqu'un
de
du service public auquel vous appartenez
vous avez un journaliste de france
télévisions qui se retrouvent en dixième
position de la réunion et en
l'occurrence pour ce qui concerne ce
qu'on appelle la section caraïbes donc
qui concerne la martinique et la guyane
est bon nous avons un martin quand 24e
position
alors si c'est ça faire la part belle
sur une liste de 23 pour cent aux
antilles il a excusé moi on repassera
merci béatrice bellay secrétaire fédéral
des socialistes martinique est également
présente sur sept listes du parti
socialiste place publique pour les
européennes du 26 mai merci bonne
journée
merci à vous
[Musique]